elles ont mis leur menace à exécution
j'ai une protection parce que maintenant
j'ai pris une protection pour nous me
permettrait d'être en sécurité chez moi
mais maintenant le chantage déterminées
elles ne pourront plus demander de
l'argent c'est fini vous êtes plutôt
soulagé donc cette histoire oui ça a été
difficile
la promesse que c'est dingue nommé
vendée content de vivre comme ça je vais
même vous dire mieux mais ma femme et
mon fils mais j'ai l'impression de te
retrouver il ya quatre ans de ça parce
que tu t'étais renfermé totalement et
maintenant où te retrouves comme à
l'époque
vous avez peur aujourd'hui ou plus ou
mois j'ai en fait j'avais c'est dur de
se dire vous mettez à payer toute ta vie
pour que rien ne sorte pour parce que
c'était un chantage constants tu as payé
tout allait pour qu'il n'ait pas de
soucis auprès des familles et maintenant
ça sort au grand jour c'est difficile
mais après au bout de quelques jours je
me suis dit mais en vrai je suis soulagé
parce que maintenant les gens ils ont
compris la vérité et maintenant je peux
enfin me justifier prendre parole de ce
qui se passait maintenant je vais plus
mentir aux gens c'est fini vous avez
porté plainte
j'ai porté plainte lors il va votre
avocat et là qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant et les téléspectateurs
écoutez j'ai entendu la dernière fois il
ya quelques jours que l avait déposé
plainte tardivement
effectivement mais il y avait déjà une
plainte qui a été déposée il ya un an et
demi par ses proches parce qu'ils se
sont rendus compte de ce qui se passait
elle l'avait caché pendant des années
donc avec un calvaire elle le disait à
personne et c'est quand ses proches sa
mère son beau-père ont été eux mêmes
contacté même pour inciter carla à
donner des chèques ou que les chèques
soient honorées et c'est que finalement
eux mêmes ils ont pris la décision de
déclencher le processus judiciaire
c'était il ya un an et demi
ça a pris un peu de temps et finalement
cette d'années a subi ne garde à vue
suite à cette plainte
le mois dernier une enquête en cours oui
tout à fait oui donc dès que après cette
menace justement de sortir toutes ses
preuves tout ces éléments soit disant
contre eux
carla qui ont été fabriqués par cette
cette voyante et toute son équipe
elle s'est sentie libérée elle est allée
déposer plainte donc c'était il ya
quelques jours et nous avons été entendu
vendredi matin par les policiers pour
développer toute la planète et tous les
éléments
est ce qu'il y avait d'autres cas comme
la digue il y en a plusieurs
je suis aussi sur ce plateau pour dire
de plus à avoir peur parce que je pense
que moi j'ai la chance d'être dans la
lumière et de pouvoir en parler ou ici
sur ce plateau mais je sais qu'à
énormément de personnes qui ont eu la
même chose que moi alors oui bien sûr
financièrement beaucoup moins élevé mais
ça reste de l'argent sur 100 euros à
quelqu'un qui en payent jmil c'est
exactement la même chose c'est du
chantage et durera quelques jours et
c'est pour ça que je suis aussi là c'est
pour dire ne plus avoir peur et que si
je peux être aussi là pour les autres je
le ferai alors carla qu'est ce que vous
avez à ajouter ce soir si je vous laisse
si j'ai ce que j'ai adressé aux
téléspectateurs parce que ça fait une
histoire incroyable il ya plein de gens
et on voulait il ya des gens qui vous
ont défendu jusqu'à la fin ça a été des
semaines et des jours très très
compliqué pour vous aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de dire à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est déjà de m'excuser auprès des
marseillais de toutes les personnes qui
ont été impliquées par sept sites par
cette affaire parce que malgré tout ils
ont rien demandé et c'est vrai que quand
ils ont découvert tout ça non pas une
inversion des choses donc je peux
comprendre qu'ils aient été énervé je
m'en excuse parce que moi les marchés ça
fait partie de ma famille malgré tout
j'ai grandi à travers eux j'ai rencontré
le père de ma fille j'ai évolué donc
c'est je veux qu'ils comprennent que il
ya en aucun cas j'ai souhaité du mal et
en aucun cas cette femme et avait des
dons de sorcellerie
et des sorts qui non plus envoyé non
c'est pas le cas donc je m'en excuse
auprès d'eux est à présent j'ai envie de
me consacrer vraiment à ma famille je
remercie vraiment d'ailleurs kevin ma
famille ma belle famille qui ont été là
pour moi et surtout le soutien de toutes
les personnes sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est énorme et c'est grâce à ça que
j'ai pu me relever et me dire non mais
pas honte
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui qui a subi ça il
faut que les gens le sachent pas ce que
ça peut aider aussi d'autres personnes
et maintenant c'est bel et bien terminé
je démarre une nouvelle vie